one more signature
our taxes are finally done great uh
what's the damage not bad
well there's one more text that isn't
listed on these forms really yeah and
it's one that every American has to pay
even though you rarely think about it
and it's not only the government doing
the taking our health insurers our phone
companies even our employers all get
their cut they're cut of what your time
[Music]
the American tax system is one of the
most complicated in the developed world
and it places a unique burden on its
citizens the average American spends 11
hours completing all the necessary
paperwork and we collectively spend
around 12 billion dollars a year on tax
preparation services and softwares not
to mention the repercussions if you get
something wrong journalist Annie Lowry
calls this the time tax a levy of
paperwork aggravation and mental effort
imposed on citizens it's the shifting of
the burden of bureaucracy from
organizations to Ordinary People and it
doesn't just refer to the IRS time taxes
are everywhere when you start looking
for them filling out forms at the DMV
time tax making multiple phone calls to
get a building permit time tax waiting
for hours in line to vote time tax now
of course it's expected that living in
the modern world will involve some
drudgery but if time is money it's fair
to quantify the hours we spend on
bureaucracy and ask whether it's
necessary or Fair especially since the
time tax unlike our formal tax system is
regressive meaning the poorer you are
the more you pay if you've never applied
for any safety net programs like food
stamps housing assistance or
unemployment benefits you might be
shocked by the number of Hoops you're
asked to jump through dozens of forms
and documents in-person interviews time
sheet logs fingerprinting drug tests and
intrusive personal questions about your
career and medical history and many of
these programs require re-certification
meaning you have to do it all over again
on a regular basis adding to the burden
is the fact that poor people are less
likely to have internet access and
desktop computers and more likely to
have frequent changes of address and
disabilities that may prevent them from
getting around easily if you're already
working two jobs to barely make ends
meet it's a big deal to get time off
work so you can ride a bus downtown and
wait in line for hours to be
interrogated by a government employee
it's not surprising that a lot of people
instead choose to just throw their hands
up and say never mind authors Pamela
Hurd and Donald Moynihan call this
phenomenon administrative burden and
there's more to it than just the time
and effort you put into paperwork which
they refer to as compliance costs
there's also the learning costs which
are the benefits you miss out on because
you don't know about them or can't
understand the complicated application
process and there's the psychological
costs which refers to the humiliation
shame or degradation that applicants
must put up with to access the benefits
they are legally entitled to now you
might think that these costs are fair
hey if you want free money you're going
to have to put up with some hassles okay
but remember that Americans of all
socioeconomic levels get financial
assistance from the government it's just
the programs aimed at the poor that seem
to treat you like a convict on parole
you don't have to pee in a cup to get a
mortgage and you don't have to be
fingerprinted to start an IRA government
programs that tend to have more white
middle and upper class beneficiaries are
typically much easier to apply for and
maintain so much so that the people who
access them are more likely to believe
that they're not on any kind of
government assistance at all there's a
long history of using bureaucracy to
discourage certain undesirable people
from participating in government in
response to the 15th Amendment which
gave non-white men the right to vote
many Southern States built bureaucratic
roadblocks like poll taxes and literacy
tests but there are other less
pernicious factors that underlie the
administrative burdens for one it saves
money the more people you can frustrate
out of the system the less you have to
pay in claims as Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis said about his State's
unemployment system I think the goal was
for whoever designed it was let's put as
many kinda pointless roadblocks along
the way so people just say oh the hell
with it I'm not going to do that this
motivation extends outside the halls of
government private insurance companies
deliberately make filing a claim such a
hassle that some percentage of valid
claimants will just give up automated
call centers save money on labor by
forcing you to spend more of your time
on the phone and employers who used to
automatically pay into pensions now
require their employees to enroll
themselves in 401ks and many of them
never get around to it but some
politicians may actually see a value in
administrative burden itself if your aim
is to shrink the size of the government
it can be helpful to cultivate an
impression of it as bloated and
inefficient the last thing you want is
for Citizens interactions with the
government to be smooth and pleasant of
course the ostensible reason for
administrative burden is to prevent
fraud and it is true there is a not
insignificant amount of Fraud and Abuse
associated with government benefits hard
numbers are very difficult to come by
but estimates vary between five and
fifteen percent of overall payouts go to
people who are technically ineligible or
are spent on things they're not intended
for however a significant amount of that
fraud is perpetrated by companies and
identity thieves not the individuals and
families who genuinely need the help and
are forced to Bear the brunt of
administrative burden the ultimate
question is whether preventing a small
amount of fraud is worth discouraging
millions of eligible Americans from
accessing their benefits unfortunately
we just don't have the data to weigh
that question accurately the amount of
time and money Americans lose to
bureaucracy has never been
comprehensively calculated we don't know
how many qualified Americans skip
benefits because of red tape or whether
these massive complex systems are
actually more wasteful than the fraud
itself without this information there's
little chance that anything will be done
about administrative burden in the short
term fortunately there are non-profit
organizations dedicated to helping
low-income people navigate it and if you
happen to be one of the few who is
naturally good at researching
application processes and filling out
forms consider yourself lucky it's a
surprisingly useful skill in our modern
ocean of bureaucracy and that's our two
cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
for more on administrative burden check
out our video why do we hate paying
taxes
foreign